mes chers camarades bien le bonjour
aujourd'hui une vidéo assez courte pour
vous orienter vers un boulot que j'ai
fait sur une autre chaîne
mais dont je suis particulièrement fier
il ya quelques temps j'ai été contacté
par l'ina l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel qui m'a donné une carte
blanche pour utiliser ses archives
du coup j'ai décidé de réaliser trois
films sur la propagande durant la
seconde guerre mondiale la guerre
d'algérie et mai 68 ces épisodes j'ai
décidé de les faire en collaboration
avec d'autres vidéaste tout d'abord
usuelle qui s'est mis à l'écriture et
vous retrouverez sa patte dans projet
mais aussi nico de la chaîne pilote qui
s'est mis au montage et qui a apporté sa
science du rythme au film cet autre
regard sur la propagande que nous
essayons d'apporter il est disponible
gratuitement sur la chaîne youtube
inna histoire et c'est près de trois
vidéos pour plus de 30 minutes de
programme bien évidemment vous mais les
liens en descriptions et n'hésitez
surtout pas à me faire vos retours et à
me dire ce que vous en avez pensé
sur ce mois je vous souhaite une bonne
journée ou soirée et à la prochaine